[Music]
I think that for all of us who are
dreaming of hoping for and committed to
creating a system that is fairer more
sustainable less unequal we all ask
ourselves the question of where do we
fit in what do we actually do what do I
do this is what other people do and I
think there's a lot that governments can
do and should do and there's a lot that
not-for-profits can and should do what
I'm very interested in is what I know
and what we know which is which is big
corporate life and what we know is that
big corporates are very powerful they
control an enormous a number of
resources human and Planetary Resources
and so the transformation of big
companies is a really important part of
the puzzle it's not the only thing but
it's a really important part of the
puzzle so I think that the more that big
companies take their responsibilities
seriously to transform the better off
the entire puzzle is going to be I think
one of the the the questions that people
ask all the time is is what can I
personally do and I think if you're an
individual you know one of the questions
that you can ask yourself is if you're
buying something you can ask where did
this thing come from and where is it
going to I think if you're a normal sort
of smallish sized company one of the
questions that you can ask yourself is
where am i leaving money on the table
because basically anything that is a
linear process is probably not as
financially efficient as it could be if
it were a circular process but I think
that the that the big question that
companies large companies like - known
and and other big multinationals can and
should ask themselves is where can we
collaborate
where can we pre compete because there's
a place for competition always will be
that's why business as a as a mechanism
is powerful competition is an important
part of
that but there is also a really
important time to collaborate and I
think that the the the journey that
we're on is kind of an exploration of
when to collaborate and when to compete
and I think that this is going to be a
really sensitive and interesting
conversation
in the years ahead because collaboration
with governments NGOs and other big
multinationals is going to be really
important in some areas and by the way
extremely helpful if we can get
legislation that you know evens up the
playing field and then continuing to
compete in areas where we can
differentiate and innovate is a really
important part of why business is a
powerful force and I think the
combination of those two things will
help business to be forceful good that
we dream it to be one of the things that
I think distinguishes b-corp
certification from many of the other
certifications is that it's holistic but
it also allows you to double down in
areas that you really want to be
exceptional in and just be okay in areas
that you that you you know you're not
choosing to double down on basically and
if you take the subject of workers for
example the question of how much
ownership your workers have of of your
organization the question of what
percentage of your workers are at or
above the living wage the question of
what's the size of the gap between the
most well-paid employee and the least
well-played employee in your
organization these are just some of the
questions that that did you need to
answer in this in this in the BIA in the
be impact assessment and what's
interesting for me is that simply being
asked those questions causes you to ask
yourself what kind of company you are
and what kind of company you want to be
so I'll give you an example we didn't we
didn't even measure the living wage we
didn't even know what the living wage
was took us months to work out what that
you know what what what our numbers were
we just didn't track them and so what
happens is a combination of I think
three things is interesting
accommodation of the questions that you
have to answer causes the leadership of
an organization to rethink the kind of
company that it wants to be secondly
there is a transparency to the whole
process that makes it very difficult to
pretend to be something that you're not
so your scores are public your you know
your ratings are public and anybody can
kind of ask the B lab the not-for-profit
whatever questions that they have about
your organization so there's not much
chance for you there's no chance really
for you to hide and I think what's
interesting about these kinds of metrics
is it's not necessarily an individual
metric it's a combination of metrics and
it's a combination of ways that you deal
with your people and the planet really
that makes you a good company or less
good company and if you've got poor
intent a lot of the metrics out there
you know you can kind of duck and dive
but because this is pretty holistic it's
very difficult to do that and because
it's transparent and I think the third
thing that's been very interesting for
us and I think it's true for pretty much
everybody on this journey is because
purpose is so important to the more
junior and the younger employees in all
organizations they get empowered to ask
questions about these kinds of things in
a way that they don't necessarily in a
traditional company so what I found very
interesting in Danone is how much
because we made the declaration to
become a B Corp it opens up the question
of what we're trying to be and it allows
people to ask questions about the things
that are covered in that assessment that
I don't think that would be asked
otherwise so I think it's a it's a
pretty interesting sort of package of
things that leads to generally a good
outcome
[Music]